hey dr. Wallach I was calling about I'd
have two questions what about my husband
and what about water my husband was born
with Nero front row mitosis I know I'm
not saying it correctly you know we have
the tumor see they're inside your body
or outside his or inside can your
product help him help him well how did
it manifest yourself does are these
tumors are they in between his bones in
his feet and it's causing problems in
his feet or is it in his chest as
causing Fehlings lungs what was it that
she has him all over his arms his back
his chest and so what are his symptoms I
mean is he feeling pain as he have
reduced range of motion well see they
just told him that the dull tumors they
grow out into the nerve well you don't
want to mess them less they bother you
because if you take one out five or six
more will grow back in this place
now he was you know have bout to pass an
out he had neck surgery that two months
later after that he started falling to
the left so they had to give him Sinemet
for Parkinson's but he don't have
parkinson's okay right how much does he
weigh how much does he weigh huh 190
okay and how it's all is he five nine
okay and let's see here you have any
other issues have a pressure diabetes
arthritis he has high blood pressure and
he does have arthritis because he was in
the same wreck I was in messed up pretty
bad okay
all right Charmaine you there I'm here
okay here's 190-pound guy he has
arthritis and it has all kinds of
spin-off stuff going on you know it
could be kind of a mix those
neurofibromatosis and fibromyalgia and
all that stuff he does have high blood
pressure okay and so what would you do
for this guy he's got musculoskeletal
stuff he's got arthritis okay and
there's neurofibromatosis and discomfort
and pain and then he also had have a
pressure what'd you do for him well for
all those different issues I might
suggest who he gets on a gluten free
diet start out with and for those issues
I would getting my help
two healthy brain and heart packs and I
would add to that he held him a daily
classy and the gluco gel okay very good
how about the sunshine but it was day
three that's okay perfect okay yeah and
so two husband or heart attacks per
month two full dose everything twice a
day the group of gel two large bowel
Singh take 15 a day five five and five
the high blood pressure the ultimate
daily classic tablets this will support
healthy blood pressures for healthy
blood flows or blocked arteries and for
discomfort and pain the CM cream and
from oil and one last thing for your
husband Shar said it and I didn't
summarize it and he should also get two
bottles a month of our vitamin d3
capsule so it can take three of those
twice a day to really make it efficient
for him to absorb the calcium minerals
and so forth and also put them in his
proper tissues in a proper way about him
in d3